Верховна Рада ухвалила законопроект про реінтеграцію Донбасу.
Захоплені сепаратистами регіони нині не лише
в політичній ізоляції, але й у комунікаційній.
Що ще залишилося від зв'язку із жителями так званих "ДНР"/"ЛНР"?
11 січня у так званих "ДНР" та "ЛНР" через розрив
кабелю перестав працювати мобільний оператор
Vodafone Україна, колишній МТС Україна.
Водафон пообіцяв відремонтувати кабель, як тільки
співробітникам буде гарантовано безпеку.
До цього компанія була єдиним українським
мобільним оператором у самопроголошених республіках.
Нема Водафон - нема і можливості, наприклад,
додзвонитися з Донецька до Києва чи Одеси.
Невизнані "ДНР" та "ЛНР" три роки тому запустили
свої власні оператори мобільного зв'язку - "Фенікс" і "Лугаком".
Вони працюють на базі захопленого обладнання
"Київстару". Зв'язок з Україною "Фенікс" не пропонує,
але при цьому, судячи з сайту, дозволяє дзвонити, наприклад,
у Буркіна-Фасо або невизнані Абхазію та Південну Осетію.
Відколи перестав працювати Vodafone, "Фенікс"
рапортує про стрімке зростання кількості абонентів.
За його даними, за перші чотири дні в нового
оператора з'явилися 50 тисяч нових клієнтів.
З тих пір, як стався розрив кабелю, для багатьох
українців єдиним способом зв'язку з рідними і
друзями став Інтернет, зокрема, додатки скайп і вайбер.
Перші українські канали сепаратисти почали
відключати ще на сАмому початку конфлікту в квітні 2014-го.
Наступного року були відключені вже всі українські телеканали.
На базі захопленого обладнання сепаратисти
стали створювати своє телебачення.
Однак переважна більшість каналів там все одно російські.
Київ намагається протидіяти.
Так, у серпні цього року в селі Бахмутівка на
Луганщині встановлено телерадіовежу з радіусом покриття 60 км.
Сигнал повинен покривати й частину непідконтрольної території.
У так званих "ДНР/ЛНР" діє місцева "Наша пошта",
яка в основному займається доставкою посилок і
вантажів як усередині невизнаних республік, так і
в Крим та російські регіони.
Крім того, є пошта "Аіст" як посередник між
Україною і непідконтрольними Києву територіями.
Звідти можна відправити посилку через "Нашу пошту",
а на підконтрольній Києву території отримати у відділенні "Нової пошти".
Офіційного прямого сполучення між
підконтрольними Києву територіями і так званими "ДНР/ЛНР" немає.
Дістатися можна лише на особистому автотранспорті,
вистоявши ось такі черги на блок-постах.
Інший варіант: доїхати на автобусі до лінії
розмежування з одного боку, потім пройти пішки
через контроль і пересісти вже на автобус
по інший бік лінії розмежування.
Також є різні приватні перевізники, які неформально
пропонують свої послуги.